"Everything as a Stream!":
How We're Embracing React Programming to Build
a Large SPA
- Anton Abilov
>> Hey, everybody!
OK, so for our next speaker, fun fact: He's
never lost a dance of limbo.
Is limbo a dance?
He's never lost limbo, just know that.
So for our next talk it's called everything
as a stream.
Let's welcome Anton Abilov.
[applause]
I won't be doing limbo on stage, but if you
want to challenge me in limbo later, I'm all
for it.
So I'm very excited to be here.
I came all the way from Norway for this conference.
It's been awesome so far.
Thanks to all of you, the organizers, and
the speakers of course.
Now we're going to talk a little bit more
about streams, and how we've embraced Functional
Reactive Programming to build a large single-page
application at Ardoq, owe at Ardoq we try
to help -- we do this by model emthem as a
graph so we map out applications, business
capabilities, their infrastructure and how
it all ties together.
It's a fairly client-side-heavy app with dynamic
generated visualizations, real-time collaboration
and also an interesting mix of technologies
that we're going to go a bit in.
So for this talk we're going to define some
concepts to give you an intro to streams and
Functional Reactive Programming.
Then we're going to hopefully give you some
motivation for why you should care, and then
we're going to present some building blocks
for building an app with RX JS and also talk
about some roadblocks that we've hit along
the way.
So Functional Reactive Programming, how many
of you have used it before.
Please raise a hand.
That's a few, not that many.
I think I can't see because of the lights,
but Functional Reactive Programming is programming
with data streams.
If you look at the languages a lot of us use,
a lot of them involve the principles of reactive
programming.
For Redux, for example, you have the store,
so that is essentially a stream, right?
What we do in reactive programming, though,
is we elevate streams and we treat them as
first-class citizens and the functional part
comes from the part that we compose them functionally,
so we map them, filter, and reduce.
There are many libraries in JavaScript for
working with streams, and in this talk we're
going to focus on RxJS which is probably the
most popular one.
I think it surpassed a million downloads had
this year and it's the only dependency of
Angular.
So RxJS is a library for transforming, composing
and querying streams of data, it implements
the observable type in JavaScript.
And many people call it LoDash for streams.
I think it's quite powerful and I like this
definition, and I hope you can see that, as
well.
So the observable is comes from reactive tensions,
Rx and it allowed us to work with async code
more easily and when interesting the observable,
I like to compare it with promises because
I think most of us have worked with promises,
so whereas a promise emits a single value,
observables emit multiple values over a period
of time.
A promise is not lazy, it begins promising
on crease, so whereas an observable is lazy,
so you can declare an observable that should
fetch data from an API, but it won't actually
start fetching until you subscribe to it.
Whereas a promise can't be canceled, observables
can be canceled seamlessly and this can be
quite powerful in some web applications, a
lot of the core contributors at RxJS work
at Netflix and their canonical example is
when a user starts buffering a video and then
goes back, with promises this can be quite
complex, while with observables, it's seamless
and kind of reflecting on these properties,
I think the more complex our single-page applications
become, the more things kind of emit over
time and the observable pattern fits much
better for dealing with this than promises.
Another reason for why you should care is
that the observable is a Stage 1 proposal
in JavaScript.
So it might actually become a part of our
language.
And RxJS have also done a lot of work in mirroring
that proposal.
So how did we come across RxJS.
We went with Redux, then we needed a way to
handle async and for simple applications you
might be fine with Redux thunk.
But if you have more complex, you might want
to look into reDutch ... we tried Redux observable
and that was the gateway drug to streams.
So on the left side here you have a typical
Redux application or a flux-architecture where
you have views that trigger actions, these
actions are reduced in the store and then
the views are described in this store to read
the application state.
What Redux observable does is it also adds
epochs into the mix.
Epochs take our actions and can also read
the store and they emit new actions, and the
store and actions are represented as RxJS
streams, so you can apply several operators
to them, and write fairly complex async code
seamlessly.
And for us streams really made sense, so for
the actions in store, I mean they emit over
time, so representing them as a stream makes
sense, but then if you think of your web applications
you also have click events, DOM events, user
reaction.
And thinking of these as streams kind of liberates
you, it makes it much easier to model complex
data flow.
And you might even think of everything as
a stream eventually.
At least for us that kind of became the case
and this is our mantra when building applications.
And while we were super-zen, like this dog
meditating, that's when reality kicked in.
It was in a quite dire state, with vast amounts
of technical debt.
So as I said, Ardoq is a startup and for the
first four years we were trying to find product
market fit and what that meant is that we
needed to add a lot of new features without
thinking much about technical debt or dealing
with that.
And kind of in the JavaScript world, that
also meant that we took a lot of shortcuts,
introduced a lot of new libraries, and it
led to a mix of paradigms that don't mix well
together.
We had a new colleague join two years ago,
and he said that our app basically showcased
the history of web development.
[laughter]
It had a mix of JQuery, handlebars, React,
Redux, all the good stuff for the bad stuff.
So it was really hard to reason about what's
going on.
If you tried to fix something over here, this
other thing broke and also state was all over
the place, and it was really hard to reason
what was going on, and I think that's where
Redux saved us is it allowed us to think easily
about our state.
The so the plans, first we to rearchitecture
mid flight.
We need to start decoupling or app.
Then we need to be able to reason about our
state and also need good interop with legacy
state and views.
So new views need to interrupt with old state
and old views and RxJS and Redux was introduced,
but then we started thinking, do we really
need Redux?
And it was great for starting from scratch,
but it was not really obvious how we introduced
it in a legacy app, especially since we had
a lot of state all over the place, simply
adding a Redux store would mean we had another
state manager and so it became an even bigger
mess and if you read the Redux documentation,
they mention RxJS and they say it works together
with Redux, but I'm going to highlight this
one paragraph and that's where they ask: Do
you really need Redux if you already use RX?
Maybe not.
It's not hard to reimplement Redux in RX.
And that's essentially what we did.
So we defined these building blocks, which
are very similar to a Redux architecture.
It's a flux-like architecture.
We have the action stream which ties everything
together.
That is subscribed by the state stream which
calculates the application state based on
actions.
Then we have view streams which is a layer
in between the states and our views, which
prepares the state for the views so that the
views can be as simple as possible, essentially
pure functions of view streams.
Finally we have routines and that's where
we contain our side effects, so similar to
epochs and Redux observable and they also
allow us to kind of decouple our application,
so I'm going to jump into each one of these.
Owe the action stream allows any part of the
action to communicate.
We define it as a subject so a subject is
a type of an observable.
Whereas an observable emits data over time,
you can also push data to a subject, using
the .next method.
And with these two lines of code we can dispatch
our first action and launch a rocket at JSConf.
However, nothing is happening yet.
So with that reintroduced routines.
Rye teens handle actions and produce side
effects.
So here's an example of a routine.
It pipes the action step.
So we filter on the launch rocket action then
we mapped that to fetching of coordinates
which could be an API call to get the coordinates
and finally if that touches successfully,
we dispatch an action to proceed.
And these are three different RxJS operators.
Of type was custom and in the middle we have
switchMap and I purposely chose switchMap
instead of flat map to show cancellation.
Essentially what switchMap does is if it starts
fetching coordinates and that takes a long
time and then another action is dispatched
to launch another rocket, the first one would
be canceled.
So that's how cancellation can easily be built
into streams.
So routines allow us to decouple our application,
because modules can simply define what they
should react to, and our views and other modules
can dispatch action, so it allows us to decouple
them.
For us that helped a lot, because we had basically
a spaghetti monster.
If one service needed to use another, it basically
imported it and if that needs to use the other
one, then you have circular dependencies and
once everything goes over the action stream
it's much easier to build a modular application.
And then we hit our first roadblock, and that
was dead streams.
So what is streamed may die.
Essentially you need to catch your errors
with RxJS.
So in this example if we fetch coordinates
and that API call fails, then it wouldn't
proceed, and that makes sense.
As you would expect.
With RxJS you need to catch errors in order
to keep your streams alive and that is actually
a pretty good feature, I think because it
forces you to catch errors and define how
your application should handle them.
Of course, for production-ready code you might
want to make it more robust by centralizing
stream creation.
Next we have state streams, so so far we have
actions and routines.
State streams emit the state of our application
and here's an example of our state stream.
So the rocket stream pipes the action stream
and accumulates state over time.
So if this batch action to launch a rocket,
it will decrement the fuel of a rocket.
It's basically a reducer, except it's now
modeled as a stream.
Now that it's modeled as a stream, we can
also do a lot of different things with them
that we're going to go into.
So one thing is that we can have derived state,
so oftentimes in your applications you have
state which depends on base state.
For example, we could have refueling cost,
which should be calculated using the fuel
price, for example, so here we pluck the fuel
from the rocket stream and then we apply distinct
until changed.
That adds memorization, so essentially it
won't emit until the fuel changes and then
we define it with a fuel price stream.
So when something subscribes to this, it would
also do an API call to get the latest fuel
price and finally we mapped that to the refueling
cost.
And normally, if you would have minimization
in a Redux, you would have to add ...
Next we have proxy state, so going back to
our requirements, we have a lot of legacy
state, and we need to interrupt with that,
we can create our own stream creators and
essentially stream our legacy state.
So here we create an observable from a backbone
model.
Whenever a backbone model syncs with a server
it also pushes that to an observable.
So we can simply subscribe to these streams
and they won't really know about backbone
being under the hood so we can later swap
out backbone easily.
So the benefits of state streams is that they're
quite expressive and powerful, yet easy to
reason about.
So going back to this slide, we have minimization
built in and once you get used to the paradigm
it's quite easy to read.
Then it has good interop with legacy state.
You could add debouncing, you have minimization
with distinct until changed.
You could add a buffer and there are many
other options, as well.
Then we hit our next roadblock and that's
cold versus hot?
So I think anyone who starts using RxJS hits
this roadblock eventually.
For those of you who are not familiar with
cold versus hot, it might also be a bit ambiguous
terms.
They didn't make much sense to me the first
time I heard them.
What it means is observables are cold by default
and then they can be made hot.
Cold observables work in the way that every
new subscriber gets its own producer.
So imagine that there's an observable which
models the Fibonacci sequence, the first subscriber
would get the whole sequence and the second
subscriber would also get the whole sequence.
And that makes sense in some cases, with API
calls, for example, you would expect that
every new subscriber would do a new API call.
However, for some cases such as state streams,
that's not really efficient, because every
new subscriber to a state stream would provide
a new producer, so it would recalculate the
state every time.
So what we can do for state streams is we
have hot observables.
So essentially it shares the producer among
all subscribers.
Basically cold versus hot is a very important
property of streams that has implications
and you need to think about this when you
define your streams.
And for streams, it's easy, we just make them
hot.
laugh
so next we have views and views is a function
of streams and I hope host of you agree that
the views should be dead simple, pure functional
components.
It makes them decouple from our business logic
and easy to change them later.
So we have view streams that pipe state streams
and prepare them for the view so the views
can be as simple as possible.
And we've created a connect utility function.
Essentially what it does is it subscribes
to a stream when the view is mounted and then
unsubscribes when it's unmounted, so the view
would update whenever the view stream updates.
Next we can also have view streams that fetch
data.
So you could define a view stream as an AJAX
call, so you could essentially fetch data
from the API when the view mounts and map
that to props for the view.
Using another operator, we could also add
initial loading props so that the view could
load something before the API call resolves,
and we could also catch errors, so with just
fivish lines of code and maybe a couple of
utility functions we have a view that's coupled
to an API call without having that API logic
in our view.
So that is essentially our building blocks
for building an application with RxJS and
now I want to reflect a little bit on the
higher level pitfalls and benefits of that.
So one thing is that RxJS is extremely flexible
and you need to invest some time in kind of
dealing with this flexibility.
Because you can really shoot yourself in the
foot when dealing with it.
Another thing is that you might end up with
streams all over the place.
I heard a podcast with Ben Lesch, the core
maintainer of RxJS, and he warns about basically
creating streams all over the place and that's
what many people do, and I like Dan, that's
the title of my talk.
However, I think you can circumvent that probably
being explicit about your streams.
So kind of the building blocks I presented,
it's not meant to be a framework or a silver
bullet or everyone it's kind of an architecture
that you can build to suit your needs and
I think RxJS is a great tool for that.
The next is that debugging can be a bit challenging
in RxJS.
Call stacks are a I will little bit long and
hide some important details, however, we have
tools to also deal with that.
So you can use RxJS spy to tag your streams
and essentially you can replay your streams,
you can stop them, similar with how you would
do with Redux DevTools and the creator is
also working on a Chrome extension so then
we'll have a similar experience and the benefits
of RxJS and streams is that it is extremely
flexible so you can do a lot of things with
the operators that RxJS provides, and I think
also one thing is the kind of the expressiveness
of reactive programming.
You can write ten lines of code with a few
operators and that defines a fairly complicated
async logic, and then it's still very easy
to reason about.
And perhaps the most important point is that
with streams, there is very little overhead
to dealing with asynchronous code because
once you kind of embrace streams, then everything
can react to anything at any point in time
so you don't really care whether it's async
or synchronous.
So I think a think I hear about JavaScript
is that we treat asyncnus if you.
If you find that async code makes things complex
in your application, or perhaps if you're
working on a large single page application
and it's difficult to reason about what's
going on.
That was the case for us.
Obviously adding reactive programming to the
mix won't solve your problems, but I really
think it will help you.
And the next is if you're using Angular or
Redux observable.
So our Angular has a single dependency, and
I think that's RxJS, but I think people who
haven't embraced it: And perhaps also if you
use Redux, you should really check out Redux
observable.
So I hope this talk was interesting and that
you might also start thinking about everything
as a stream.
[applause]